hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich kann
jetzt richtig auf den Tisch hauen weil
das Mikrofon steht hier nicht mehr ich
versuche jetzt mal mit so einem kleinen
Mikro hier ist glaube ich nicer keine
Ahnung ich weiß nicht warum ich da nicht
vorher drauf gekommen bin aber gut ich
bin halt ein bisschen dumm im
Hintergrund ist auch was neu ihr seht
schon da ist jetzt so ein V also das V
wird auf jeden Fall auch noch ein
bisschen größer es geht noch weiter nach
oben es sieht jetzt halt clean aus ne
ich habe ja auch bei dem openschild
dieses Kabel weggemacht in so einem
Kabelkanal
ja das haben ja so viele geschrieben
dass ich das machen soll auf der anderen
Seite sind die Neon science ganz weg ich
weiß nicht ob ich die wieder hin machen
soll keine Ahnung irgendwie bin ich
nicht so ganz zufrieden was ja ehrlich
sagen aber ich habe mir auch einen neuen
PC und so geholt und das ist vor allem
auch für die Livestreams die ich machen
möchte der Hintergrund dann halt Link
dazu ist in der Videobeschreibung wir
machen heute etwas sehr nices jetzt muss
ich auch hier oben in der Ecke Werbung
einbinden weil die Box die wir Auspacken
habe ich umsonst von xiaomi zur
Verfügung gestellt bekommen viele von
euch kennen die Firma wahrscheinlich
auch unter xiaomi weil es mit X
geschrieben wird aber es wird xiaomi
ausgesprochen eine absolut Geisteskranke
technikmarke die machen so viel Zeug
mein allererster Saugroboter war auch
von denen die machen wirklich alles
Mögliche was man sich nur vorstellen
kann Handys Kopfhörer Bildschirme Smart
TV und das alles finde ich zu einem sehr
guten Preis-Leistungsverhältnis ich habe
hier die Box bekommen passend zum Black
Friday ich zeige euch die mal so sieht
das Ganze aus ist gar nicht sonderlich
schwer aber mir wurde gesagt hier ist
auf jeden Fall eine Menge cooles Zeug
drin und ich bin super gespannt das
ganze wird natürlich auch zu den Sachen
kann es nicht sehen aber da ist dieser
Riesenhaufen so Dezember Verlosung
gepackt also es wird immer mehr und
immer mehr und es kommt noch so viel
hinzu oh man da könnt ihr euch auf jeden
Fall darauf freuen und wir machen das
ganze jetzt mal vorsichtig auf ach so
das ist hier noch zugeklebt glaube ich
will es eigentlich gar nicht kaputt
machen weil die Box sieht so nice aus oh
nein let's go eins zwei drei vier Sachen
haben wir drin und Kugelschreiber
Kugelschreiber kann man auf jeden Fall
immer gut gebrauchen aber das ist ja
langweilig im Vergleich zu dem es ist
auch geil Alter wir haben ein geiles
Handy ich weiß welches Handy das ist ich
hatte es noch nie und ich freue mich
umso mehr dass ich da jetzt drin liegt
es ist auf jeden Fall ein fettes Handy
und ich starte aber erstmal mit den
Sachen die wahrscheinlich nicht so
interessant sind aber trotzdem nein zum
Beispiel haben wir hier habe ich gerade
gesehen ein Mädchen wie Stick wenn ihr
kein Smart TV habt könnt ihr einfach
diesen mit TV Stick in euren Fernseher
stecken und habe dann automatisch
Netflix Youtube Prime alles mögliche
halt was man so braucht ich habe
allerdings ein Smart TV deswegen kann
ich das nicht gebrauchen aber ich lege
es natürlich zu den ganzen Sachen wir
können eigentlich auch mal kurz
Auspacken weil ich muss sagen ich habe
diesen Stick so noch nie gesehen also an
denen der wenn man irgendwann mal kriegt
tut mir leid dass der schon auf ist
dafür dass die Verpackung schon
eingerissen ist oh mann tschuldigung
also ziemlich simpel so wie man sich das
vorstellt einfach hier kann es im
Fernseher stecken mit HDMI-Anschluss und
let's go ich glaube mehr muss ich dazu
auf jeden Fall nicht sagen für dieses
interessiert blende ich hier auch die
Summe von dem Produkten ein damit man
halt so weiß wie viel wert hier drin ist
interessiert mich selber auch deswegen
mache ich das einfach mal wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten Produkt und zwar
haben wir hier aha da bin ich ja der
absolute Profi me to wireless earbuds
Base ja ich weiß gar nicht Alter in
schwarz und ich habe gesehen wir haben
dazu auch noch andere in weiß das sind
allerdings die Metro wireless earphones
2 basic bevor wir die jetzt auspacken
und dann mal testen muss ich noch darauf
hinweisen dass ich zusammen mit schaumi
diesen Freitag von 12 bis 14 Uhr ein
Livestream veranstaltet und zwar auf der
offiziellen xiaomi Deutschland Website
me.com und das Ganze zum Glück nicht
alleine sondern zusammen mit Info denn
kennen wahrscheinlich viele von euch ihr
könnt ihn euch hier mal ein wir werden
uns auf jeden Fall dahin setzen das
ganze findet statt im Saturn in Köln und
Stream von da aus machen geile
challenges es gibt eine Menge coole
Verlosung es gibt Rabattaktion und so
weiter deswegen willst du mich mega
freuen wenn ihr alle am Freitag in den
Livestream kommt von 12 bis 14 Uhr ganz
oben in der Videobeschreibung verlinke
ich euch das da könnt ihr einfach auf
den Link klicken wie gesagt geile
Verlosung es wird sich lohnen und ich
hoffe ich kann auf euch zählen und ja
jetzt checken wir mal hier die earphones
ab ihr butts was auch immer achso nee
beides auch hier habe ich euch sicher
schon den Preis eingeblendet ich habe
gerade gesehen die sind ziemlich
preiswert diese hier kosten 22,99 so
warm ach hier sind tatsächlich nur die
Kopfhörer drin also in meinem Fall
absolut gar kein Problem weil ich habe
eine Milliarden von diesen Kabeln aber
wenn man halt keins hat ja gut das hat
heutzutage anscheinend jeder deswegen
die werden sich schon was bei gedacht
haben wirkt auf jeden Fall sehr
hochwertig danke schon mal dafür wir
machen jetzt hier dann noch die earphon
natürlich auch sehr gut und die
Kopfhörer sind noch mal einzeln hier
neben dann baller ich die mal hier ins
Case Zack und so sieht das dann aus
finde ich auf jeden Fall sehr cool wir
schauen gleich mal welche von beiden
besser finde welche dem besseren Klang
haben aber ich hole jetzt erstmal das
Handy hier raus und werde die Kopfhörer
dann auch damit connecten bietet sich an
die haben wir das Meet and light auf
jeden Fall ein ziemlich geiles
Smartphone ich habe schon vieles darüber
gehört hat natürlich auch seinen Wert
ich glaube das kostet um die 500 €
blende ich hier euch super gerne auch
ein ich bin so gespannt weil das Dingen
hat wohl eine absolut Kranke Kamera wir
werden sehen und die gute Nachricht für
euch ich gehe mal stark davon aus am
Freitag am Black Friday im Livestream
wird davon auch vielleicht das ein oder
andere rausgehauen designt bei xiaomi
okay was haben wir hier drin ein Case
wird auch mitgeliefert ich bin nicht so
der Fan von cases weil ich finde einfach
das macht die Schönheit die Eleganz von
Smartphones einfach kaputt okay gut
eigentlich ist es sehr dumm weil sonst
geht halt dein Smartphone kaputt und
hier haben wir dann schon das Smartphone
und was mal raus gebt Euch das hier vier
Kameras hier haben wir nur das Ladekabel
drin Kopfhörer sind nicht dabei habe ich
aber jetzt auch genug ich würde sagen
wir machen es einfach mal an ich sehe
gerade hier schon man kann sogar zwei
SIM-Karten reintun dann kannst du einmal
das als Arbeits Handy neben theoretisch
und auch noch privat weil es gibt ja
sehr viele die meinen sie müssen
unbedingt zwei Handys besitzen let's go
also ich finde das Design wirklich ultra
nice gerade durch diese lila blauen
Farben aus dem Hintergrund wird das hier
so schön reflektiert okay da hatten wir
mal ich richte das mal eben ein und dann
checken wir das mal aus okay Leute Handy
ist hochgefahren so sieht das aus ich
konnte gerade wählen zwischen zwei
Designs ich habe mich für limitless
entschieden deswegen das ist so ein
bisschen dunkler oh tinder ist auch
direkt schon drauf sehr gut kein Spaß es
sind aber wirklich einige Apps schon
drauf Netflix ist drauf youtube ist
drauf spiele sind schon drauf eigentlich
muss man sich das ja sonst immer selber
noch runterladen youtube ist drauf
Youtube music ich muss eigentlich direkt
mal die Kamera Auschecken weil die sieht
ja so fett aus die muss jetzt auch geil
sein einmal kurz mit duckface so wie
früher
man sieht halt voll meine Augenringe
einfach weil die Qualität so hoch ist
aber gut dann checke ich jetzt mal die
Kopfhörer ab welche davon besser sind
ich bin gespannt vor allem ja auch weil
ich letztes Jahr eine Menge Kopfhörer
getestet habe die alle ungefähr bei
diesem Preis lagen so hier haben wir
schon mal die ehephonse 2 basic die
Koppeln war mal eben hier wird auch
direkt der Akku Zustand angezeigt 70 %
beim Case 36 % bei den Kopfhörern sieht
das stylisch gut aus ich weiß es nicht
werde ich gleich sehen und jetzt hör mal
hier mal rein
[Musik]
absolut gut für 30 Euro ich meine die
kostet nicht mal 30 € kann man sich
nicht beschweren sehr guter Klang ich
bin jetzt mal gespannt auf die hier ich
gehe aber mal davon aus die hier sind
besser weil die sind auch letztens erst
rausgekommen also auf jeden Fall neuer
als die schwarzen hier aber an sich muss
das ja nichts heißen wir koppeln dann
jetzt mal die anderen hier gehen wir mal
raus die liegen halt auch ganz anders im
Ohr weil du diesen Tropfen hier dran
hast aber gut dann bin ich auch damit
verbunden hören wir mal eben rein auch
auf jeden Fall absolut akzeptabel wobei
die weißen hier schon besser sind die
kann ich euch auf jeden Fall sehr
empfehlen ich muss sagen im Großen und
Ganzen ich bin großer Fan von der Marke
weil ich finde die machen halt absolut
preiswerte Technik und deswegen freue
ich mich sehr auf den Livestream am
Freitag wollen wir auf Jumbo und es wird
sehr sehr nice kommt dann bitte
unbedingt in den Stream alle Sachen die
ich hier von xiaomi zugeschickt bekommen
habe kommen da hinten hin die werden im
Dezember alle verlost deswegen lohnt es
sich umso mehr den Kanal zu abonnieren
natürlich auch das Handy ich habe da
hinten noch ganz viele andere Handys es
kommen noch weitere dazu und ja danke
fürs zuschauen Leute und wir sehen uns
die Woche wieder es kommt nämlich
endlich das Video mit den zehn Laptops
die ich wiederholen bestellt habe also
das war's haut rein ciao